the main protagonist in this drama is a
u.s. president Donald Trump he's leading
the charge aggressive and unpredictable
his strategy is to exert so much
pressure that the other players make
concessions he announced tariffs on
steel and aluminium imports then
suspended them for the EU and a few
others his declared target is China
which he accuses of technology theft and
unfair trading practices Trump intends
to slap tariffs on 60 billion dollars of
Chinese imports a year it's a risky bet
for many reasons Trump claims the u.s.
is being cheated by other countries in
the realm of global trade his mantras
are America first and make America great
again he's promised to revive
manufacturing at home the US has a
significant Rust Belt regions where the
steel and auto industries among others
collapsed in the face of foreign
competition Chinese President Xi Jinping
is the key counterpart to the
protagonist Trump China wants to avert
an all-out trade war it wants to make
money and enhance its global economic
reach it's presenting itself as a
champion of free trade it said it plans
to impose duties on three billion
dollars worth of imports from the US
including pork Apple's wine and steel
pipes but it's also indicated that it
might consider targeting major players
such as Boeing Apple and Intel
China is the world's largest producer of
steel
exports to the US are hit with tariffs
it will likely seek to boost sales
elsewhere including Europe it's also
possible that the u.s. might threaten to
impose tariffs on clothes and high-tech
goods from China or even do so if China
wants to play hardball and launch a
large-scale retaliation
it might consider slowing its purchases
of US Treasuries it already holds more
US debt than anyone else
a third player is Cecilia malmström the
European Union's trade commissioner in
tough talks with a US administration she
got the tariffs on steel and aluminium
suspended though only temporarily Trump
has set a deadline of May the first to
finalize a deal on trade and once
concessions the EU is seeking to
de-escalate the crisis the last thing it
wants is a trade war a lot is at stake
especially for Germany with its huge
trade surpluses for example it sells a
lot of cars in the United States the
European Union says the deadline of May
the first for a deal is unrealistic
that's when a suspended tariffs are set
to go into force the fight with Trump is
not over yet